hello everybody and welcome to another
debugging Python tutorial video in this
video we're going to be talking about
the following error right here import
error DLL load failed percent 1 is not a
valid win32 application the reason
you'll see this error is you're trying
to intermix a 32-bit something with a
64-bit something or vice versa in my
case
what I've done is I attempted to import
PI brain and I got this error now
normally this would mean the PI brain
was the incorrect bit version however in
my scenario that's actually not the case
it's a little more complex I the PI
brain is the correct and if you come
down here you'll see the last thing an
attempted to do was import something
from sy PI and it turns out that sy PI
is actually the incorrect bit version
not PI brain
now again normally it will indeed be
what you attempted to import but
sometimes it won't be and that could
really throw throw you for a curve
because you might not you really pull
your hair out when that happens and in
this case what it what happened was I
haven't used sy PI since I upgraded to
64-bit Python so when I installed sy PI
it was a 32-bit version because Python
that I had was 32-bit since then I
upgraded it 64-bit so I wasn't being
restricted anymore by that 2 gigabyte
limit so if that's an error that you're
seeing you're trying to import something
that is the wrong bit value now one last
thing I will add if you are running a
64-bit version of Python many modules
are not available in 64-bit and you'll
basically end up with this error if you
try to download the only available
option so what can you do and actually
you're probably wanting to get here so
like if I try to download 32-bit version
of sy PI right now it would tell me it
can't find Python in my you know it
doesn't can't find Python on my machine
so anyway so you probably wouldn't even
get here but you would get here if you
had previously installed it then you
upgraded or downgraded your pythons bit
version then you could wind up like this
but anyways so some of these things like
pi doesn't actually have a 64-bit
installer but I actually do have a video
available on where you can go to get
64-bit installers or you could recompile
it yourself and do that if you can
otherwise you can visit that website on
video I'll put it in the description
maybe add an annotation if I don't
forget and if I do forget just leave a
comment and I will add those things in
there so hopefully that helps you guys
from pulling out your hair too much as
always thanks for watching thanks for
your support your subscriptions and
until next time